YouTube is currently underneath the process of terminating terminating
my >> Basically, he'd gone after Froggy for being fat like
a dozen times and his partner manager told him on Twitch, "We've
given you multiple warnings. If you do it again, we will have
to ban you." There are entire channels of nearly a million subscribers
that are built entirely on Hassan, what the [__]
are you saying?
the live Techy reaction. Now, the title "YouTube is terminating
my channel"
posted on his YouTube channel.
Immediately, I think, "Well, that's already a lie, but what could
that possibly mean?" What That You're You're lying. Why would
you give me this good information? This is like potential good
news and it's just an obvious lie. This [__] up.
1,000 black tank tank tops with all of the cat hair or dog hair
on them. Thing is becoming progressively like faded and gross
over time.
Uh and the tank top as well. >> I haven't seen y'all in
a week and to give you guys a TLDR of what this video is about
to be about, I'm going to tell you guys why YouTube is currently
underneath the process of terminating terminating my channel
as well as I am now going to be streaming exclusive
There's no process of terminating your channel. There is you
can get community guideline strikes or you can get copyright
strikes. There's no like process of terminating your channel.
That is not a thing that they do.
There's reactions to your action,
But there is no process towards terminating your channel. sively
live on Rumble which the link is underneath in the description.
I would appreciate all you guys giving me a follow. YouTube videos
will still be on YouTube. However, I am not streaming on any
other platform besides Rumble from here until the very far future.
So, let me tell you where I've been and why you guys haven't
seen a post from me in now 7 days.
Uh it is because you had a community guidelines strike, right?
>> Um, so, I am a content creator where the thing that
I pride the most in myself is being able to be as transparent
as possible when allowed unless a legality comes into play where
I get to tell my chat everything that I'm thinking, everything
that I want to say, and the exact way that I want to say it.
what's going on right now is there is a parade of content creators
who are currently abusing the copyright strike
uh feature on YouTube.
Number one, Hasan [__] Number two, and I [__]
you not, this just happened So, yes, just to be clear, when he
does talk Hasan Hasan is bad. Okay. Just really quick, let's
just follow that that thread. Rumble exclusive. Does he mean
not on Kick? If he means not on Kick, then what really happened
here is he was offered a deal from Rumble, an exclusive streaming
deal on Rumble, which he accepted.
That is the only possible situation that makes any sense, okay?
If he was not getting exclusive deal to stream on Rumble, he
would just stream on Kick where he can make a [__]
ton of right? But that's not what he's doing. He is going to
stream on Rumble. So, obviously, he got a pro like a a good deal
from Rumble to go stream there. They're trying to build up the
streaming section, I guess. All right, and he's taking them up
on that offer.
I don't know, it's uh
It's like I good, I guess. I would love to see Now, if somebody
could if somebody wants to look, I I should have thought of this
beforehand. I'm just thinking about it I want to see what happens
when Miskif goes to Rumble. Does Tecktonet have commentary on
Miskif going to Rumble? What did Tecktonet say about Miskif taking
a Rumble deal? Cuz I'm I'm guessing he had a commentary.
What would it be? Very interesting. Okay. Today, BabyNoMoney.
Uh, BabyNoMoney Wait, BabyNoMoney copyright struck you? >> copyright
struck West Jet and Hassan copyright struck my channel as well.
Wait, so baby no money didn't copyright strike you?
Baby no money copyright struck West Jet and not you? What?
What? I've actually seen the West Jet thread, so I I might pull
that up on the screen right now. >> Grande.
Yes, so we currently have a couple warnings on our channel as
well as a strike. Um, and the reason why for this one will blow
blow your mind. Uh, out of everything that I say on this channel,
and I guys, I get it. Sometimes I say some crazy things. I don't
really think I say anything too diabolical, but all I said was
due to and I'm going to have my
I'm going to have to censor a lot of things that I say going
forward, hence why I'm very glad I'll be streaming on Rumble
very soon because what's going to happen is I'm going to stream
completely unsensored on Rumble because I've never heard of a
single person What are you What are you getting out that's that's
so [__] up? Dude, all he's describing is not being
able to stop violating
Right? Like if if these are fake strikes, if they're fake copyright
strikes, you can fight them.
And you should be broadcasting that they're fake.
Right? I haven't seen him talk about the Hassan copyright strikes.
I would love to see what happened there, if that is a thing that
happened, right? He should be broadcasting that cuz I would be
totally against If Hassan is taking totally legitimate reactions
from Tectone and copyright striking them, I would I would call
Hassan out for that. But I've not seen anything about that. Have
we seen anything like that? Hassan has like 500 fan channels.
Yeah, but I don't think, um, they they shouldn't be able to copyright
strike on his behalf. So, he should clean that up.
Yeah, I know he's not personally striking Tectone. He should
still clean it up if that is happening. Okay?
Anyway, just he mentioned baby no money with West Jet. You I
can already tell what's happening. He doesn't have really something
to complain about. He's just being like an ass and he's getting
he's getting called out by people or he's getting community guideline
strikes, right? He doesn't like it. He got a he got a fresh Rumble
contract and so he decided to roll this into some sort of performative
outrage thing for himself. He's I don't know if he's shown any
evidence of any of the other stuff, okay? But he's trying to
manufacture outrage for himself and get people behind going and
following him on following him on Rumble, right? Painting himself
as a victim. In fact,
what happened with WestJet? WestJet came out hot, okay? WestJet
did come out hot. Said the channel is to strike now. This dude
is such a fraud.
Personal email, too. Okay? I do believe BB No Money
messaged WestJet personally
I think after this.
Right? Post is deleted by author. And BB No Money messaged him
and said, "Hey, I didn't hate your video. Uh we're not trying
to strike it. Like, my bad." Right? Oh, but I think I think WestJet
Oh, I see. BB No Money messaged WestJet and said, "Hey, I I'm
not trying to strike your video. Uh I'll get it fixed." And it
did get fixed, but now the weird thing is is I could have sworn
maybe the post above this could have been somewhere WestJet like
posted DMs between him and BB No Money saying BB No Money messaged
me. But then he says this dude is such a fraud because now the
strike is removed, okay? The video's back, the strike is removed,
and he's like, "Oh, I'll delete the tweet cuz that's all I wanted."
Did he call him out after again? I Is this trying to clean things
up? Cuz I swear he posted DMs from BB No Money and said, "I'm
going to leave the tweet up just until it gets resolved." Cuz
like the tweet about the original
And then I see another tweet calling this guy a fraud. I'll take
my post down, too. Too much to Too much [__] to already
debunk in BB No Money for.
Oh, sorry. Dunk in BB No Money for.
Don't need to perpetuate what I will now assume is a genuine
mistake.
All right. All right. Interesting. So, he Tectone has rolled
this into his video for some reason. And I've not seen anything
about the copyright strikes on his channel. ever be banned on
that platform for anything they've ever said. And then I'm going
to have to sanitize it a bit on YouTube, unfortunately, just
to make sure my channel has a much higher chance of not getting
deleted while these copyright strike claims come off.
Ugh, he spits like this. It's gross.
I do wonder what the copyright strikes are. I want to see who
they're actually from. Cuz he says they're from Hasan.
Hasan doesn't copyright strike things. Hasan lets anybody review
his stuff.
Right? Hasan doesn't even go after actual fan channels just doing
full VOD uploads. Hasan doesn't even go after fan channels re-streaming
his stream live.
Hasan doesn't do any of this. So, to me, I Yeah, I got to assume
Tectone's lying. And he just wanted to throw Hasan in
And by the way, that's not necessarily virtuous from Hasan, right?
It's just a It's work to do that. It's not necessarily virtuous,
and it doesn't It's nothing to Not to say that AustinOx couldn't
do it if he wanted to.
But unless Tectone posts some proof, I do not believe him at
all. So, what I said was is that Hasan had some
rage for Asmongold, and he
He got a community guidelines strike because of something he
said about Hasan. Hmm.
>> often fantasizes about Asmongold and him sharing a lovely
night together. Um I'll kind of just let you guys fill in the
pieces, but that's that's in essence what I said. And I'm not
going to lie. I I am a [__] talker. I I absolutely
am. Because that's the world where I was born into. Where people
talk [__] people say some crazy things. Now, obviously
we don't make up any crazy ass [__] where they're
like, "Oh, this guy's a cannibal. Oh, this guy's a Oh, this guy's
a
Obviously, we don't go to any extent that much, but back in my
Okay.
Do we Do we really think like this guy's a Okay, this guy's a
cannibal. Nothing crazy like this guy's a cannibal. I day, we
used to say things like, "I'm going to [__] your
mom in the ass." Or, "I [__] your mom." In whatever
orifice Dude. That's his version of the thing Go Go to follow
my Rumble channel so you can get revolutionary commentary like,
"I [__] your mom in the ass."
Can't say that on YouTube.
I We used to say things like, "I [__] your mom in
the ass. I [__] your mom in some hole." Wow, I'm
on my way to make a Rumble account, man. That's That's sick comedy.
>> orifice you want to imagine.
But, the world has come has become far too soft for people like
me to not be heavily censored into it. We currently live in a
world Wait. Hold on. Hold on. Actually, wait. >> [__]
your mom. I say things like, "I'm going to [__] your
mom in the ass." Or, "I [__] your mom." In whatever
orifice you want to imagine.
He realized that
He explain Dude, was he disgusted by the idea that he might [__]
someone's mom in And so he had to clear it up. Whatever hole
you might imagine. Whatever hole you might imagine. Like the
idea that he if he left it dangling there, if he just said I
[__] your mom without saying in the ass or anything
specific, that could imply he wanted to [__] a which
he does not want to do. That That just gross That's just totally
gross him out. He had to clear it up immediately.
But, the world has come has become far too soft for people like
me to not be heavily censored into it. Uh we currently live in
a world where feelings
uh outweigh
the law, where feelings uh are taken into Where?
Wha- Where do feelings outweigh the law?
What? Dude. We live in a world where feelings outweigh the law.
Brother, you comment on everybody Everybody's YouTube videos
who talks you. You are the softest person on planet Earth. Who
are you? You cried when Hasan said your dad was a You cried and
talked about the times you were assaulted and when your dad almost
killed you. YOU ARE THE SOFTEST human being on planet Earth.
What in What in God's name are you talking about right now? Everyone
else is soft. You are the softest person. You bawled like [__]
on your stream because Hasan called you a Get the [__]
out of here. >> do account more than proof and evidence.
And if you cry and you say that your feelings hurt, you will
win in every
I'm mocking you. I'm mocking you for crying like a [__]
when Hasan called you a
Are you winning? You cried. You Your feelings were hurt. Did
you win? You feel like you're winning? Are you winning, son?
I can't imagine so. >> ever a part of, especially if you're
You know You know how we know he's winning? He just signed a
Rumble exclusive streaming deal.
Nothing but winners doing those. a woman side note. And it's
just be Speaking of, it's entirely possible that I sign a Rumble
deal at some point in the future. So, Rumble, just know that's
not a shot at you. It's really just a shot at Tech Tone and the
cadre of creators you've signed up to this moment, okay? At some
point in the future that might change. I will happily accept
the money. So, don't want to [__] talk Rumble, okay?
Just coming back to let me know become very difficult for me
to do what I want to do the way I want to do it, which blows.
I've been doing this content creating thing for
almost 8 years now. Which is crazy to say. Yeah, when I started
my channel, I was a prime young age of 24, and now I'm 32, feeling
the best I've ever felt, looking the best I've ever looked in
my entire life, uh, lifting the most I've ever lifted in my entire
life. Speaking of which, I'm pretty sure I can bench 315 now.
I'm going to make an update video on that
Mhm, I'm not going to say it's
Is the guy really big? Benching 315 with no shoulder definition
at all? No chest or shoulder definition at all.
it's not impossible. It's actually not impossible, but like I
I would have to see the videos or something. That seems crazy
to me. I'd believe 225 cuz he's got a big frame, a big lanky
frames, or a big lanky frame. But like, yeah, just he's got no
shoulder definition at all. I would expect something. >> Um,
but unfortunately,
Like if I'm lifting and dude >> who are long-standing fans
of my streams on YouTube or my streams on Twitch,
Uh, hold on. I do know that, Billy Joe >> I don't think
I'm ever going to go back to those.
I've been banned
for calling an editor, I'm going to need you to blank blank this
out. Um, you can write out a censored version if you want, or
people can fill in the gaps if you want. I got
If he just says, "I got banned from Twitch for calling Frogan
fat." And I got banned from Twitch for call for calling Denims
a Yeah, your editor is not going to beep that out, bro. Your
editor will not beep that out. >> banned for 2 weeks for
calling Denims a when she actively prostitutes herself live on
OnlyFans.
I got banned
dude, not even the editor cares about what Ty Tone's saying,
okay? "Editor, I'm going to need you to beep this out." Nah.
banned for another 2
>> for calling Frogan fat. When I believe she's 5'2" and
above 300 lb.
I got banned
She's definitely at above 300 lb anymore, but >> Hassan
is gay.
When he frequently talks about
Also, does Denims have an OnlyFans now or is he just talking
about the the Patreon or the the Fansly or whatever she's got?
I know it's not a big differentiation to make, but I would say
OnlyFans a lot of times to have like a non not safe for work
OnlyFans is pretty
But having a like non not safe for work Fansly is less rare.
That's just like lewds or cosplay photos. Less rare. So, it it's
just like a continuation of the language thing. You're kind of
pushing people in a direction to think Denims spreading her vag
on OnlyFans. Not happening as far as I know. Every other word
of his stream, if he stubs his toe, he blames it on Asmongold.
And it's just getting very exhausting.
Because these are the same people where Hassan calls Asmongold
He calls NuxTaku a He calls me a He says that Asmongold
is responsible for his own mother's death. He celebrates terrorism.
He says American soldiers deserve PTSD and 9/11
I mean I mean I mean I mean I don't I don't want to be rude.
Who's taking care of Asmongold's mom and let her have cigarettes
around an oxygen tank?
I just If there's If there's like a caretaker there, then the
caretaker's at
That's all I would say. And I hope that wasn't Asmongold cuz
that would be tough, okay? But I hope I hope it wasn't. Cuz that'd
be that'd be just be
Ah, no, I don't even mean that. You Dude, somebody who's smoking
will sneak smokes, okay? I don't even think it's I don't think
it's necessarily his fault. God, I wish I could just say it.
Didn't get banned for any of these things. Same thing with D'Angelo
she goes around calling everybody random criminal accusations
left right center Frogan same deal criminal accusations left
right center says America deserves 9/11 and I don't know when
all of these social media platforms became so anti-American so
anti-free speech but So anti-American so anti-free speech.
Well, he's complaining that people don't get banned for saying
bad things.
I don't know when these platforms became so anti-American so
anti-free speech. Criminal accusations left right center Frogan
same deal criminal accusations left right center says America
deserves 9/11 and I don't know when all of these social media
platforms became so anti-American so anti-free speech but it
makes me sick and I hate how I have to take these countermeasures
where I don't get to stream in places like YouTube and twitch
anymore a place for my home or a a Bro, I guarantee you watch
this guy's segments on Rumble they're not going to be things
that are TOS on twitch or YouTube. He just is a sensitive low
impulse control who sometimes will throw out a slur because he's
feeling particularly emotional in that given moment in time.
I honestly probably not even as big a deal now that he's not
on steroids anymore. I'm guessing he's got his emotions a lot
more in check at this point maybe.
Like what did he say? The thing he's apparently got community
guideline struck for didn't seem that bad. I'd have to see it.
But the other stuff it's like dude all you have to do is not
go after these people that you explicitly were told not to go
after. Like basically he'd gone after Frogan for being fat like
a dozen times and his partner manager told him on twitch stop
doing it. She's like complained a couple times. If you do it
again, right? We've given you multiple warnings. If you do it
again, we will have to ban you. You will get a temp ban. And
then he did it again.
It's It's like, "Hey, you shouldn't be doing this. There are
TOS rules against bullying somebody, and you are pushing it way
past the line like of being warned multiple times.
So, stop. I I think it's like kind of gay that they have that
rule there. I think it kind of sucks. But, they do have the rule.
It is just a rule.
And you were warned.
Yes, he acts like he just said it one
And it wasn't just one time. They warned you not to do it. They
said, "Don't do this. Don't do this. We don't want this." And
then you did it anyway.
Like, I'm I'm sorry.
What did you expect to happen? Uh a place where my viewers know
as TeckTone's home, wherever they get to go here and they know
that I'll always be live every day at 9:00 a.m. CST to 1:00 p.m.
CST, which I still will be on
once again, which will be linked in the pinned comment in the
description, which I encourage you guys to go follow.
But, it's just exhausting.
Because, obviously, I would like to multi-stream, but because
I'm going onto a completely new platform, and I'm starting from
ground zero. I I kid you not, guys. I'm starting from the beginning.
Zero viewers. I have zero
That's what this entire video is, right? This entire video is
just a cope, a lie, to try to drive people to go follow his Rumble
stream.
That's what it is.
Cuz he One, he knows that the audience is going to be there.
Two, Rumble is by far the most lax on botting, by far, okay?
Rumble's going to pay him a flat fee, I can almost guarantee.
He's going to pay get paid a flat fee from Rumble, and he can
bot as much as he wants. You can make it look like you're huge
over there, TeckTone. You can look massive,
Cuz he's just going to be getting a flat hourly rate or something,
and they don't care what his viewership is.
Yeah, make that counter go as high as you like. But, he wants
the followers there, so it doesn't look totally disingenuous.
So, he's trying to get as many people over as he possibly can.
All right. Zero viewers on this platform. I'm going to be rebuilding
everything from the ground up because I actually believe that
Rumble is a platform where I will actually be safe on and not
get banned for some again. It sucks that I have to worry about
the sanctity and the longevity of my channels, but that's just
what happens when you are a guy who tells it how it is.
And that's what sucks. That's what happens when you don't pander
to people's feelings, when you don't lie to people because you
need to tell them a certain lie. That's what happens when you
speak up saying, "Hey, I don't believe that we should be experimenting
transgenderism on children." That has gotten me Not banned though.
What do you mean it's gotten you a What the [__]
does that mean? Yeah, all you need to know, this is the best
point Lily Luna. This is the best point.
All you need to know about Techtone
is Asmongold streams on the platform that he says you can't talk
on. And he is like diet Asmongold. He doesn't even go anywhere
near as hard as Asmongold does. He's just a low impulse control
freak. That's it. Right? He can't stop himself from saying things
he knows are over the line. Asmongold can. Asmongold quite regularly
walks to the line and stops there and talks and then walks away.
Techtone, no such control. He gets barreling in a direction,
he can't stop himself from crossing the line.
But ultimately, Asmongold says way crazier [__] than
Techtone does. It is not the TOS on these platforms that is like
unreasonable, it's not
He just wants to be able to be like the the petulant child that
he is and so he's going to go over to Rumble. That's it. Which
is crazy. It's It's nuts. Or hey, just because you're fat doesn't
mean that you're beautiful. Shaming the body positivity movement
because yeah, if somebody's fat, you need to tell them that they
need to lose weight or else they're going to die.
Unfortunately, we live in a reality, we live in a world
Okay. Do you think there's any other way to do that? Was that
Was that why you're going after Frogan? You actually just didn't
want Frogan to die. Hey Frogan, it's really important because
I care about you. I want you to be healthy. That's why I'm going
to spam this picture of you Sorry, of Jabba the Hutt with your
Jabba the Hutt wearing a hijab, okay?
Like he did that He's basically implying that he did that because
he cares about Frogan being like healthy. If you did If you care
about Frogan being healthy, she's lost a bunch of weight, you
probably wouldn't be saying she's 5'2" 300 lb in your video,
right? Right?
>> where feelings and emotions outweigh >> the 12
months back. >> documented evidence and proof.
And it's pathetic. And people like me get punished for that [__]
on a day-to-day basis.
But I have never been more motivated. I have never been more
focused on making it as a content creator and operating the best
that I can to not get banned again. I'm going to get banned again.
Everybody's such a
these days. And you know what they do to guys like me? They try
to label me as a
By the way, I'm I victimize myself less over my actual YouTube
termination than Teccy don't victimize himself over a channel
strike or a copyright strike.
Like I don't constantly moan to this extent. And I wasn't even
banned for the things I said. I was banned for watching a video
of somebody else saying something bad, okay?
It's actually crazy to me that Teccy don't can sit here and be
such a victim all the god damn time to the point that he has
to lie to make himself a bigger victim constantly.
They try to label me as a criminal to get people to stop listening
to me, but you got to
Also, yes.
What did they label you? >> [__] these days.
And you know what they do to guys like me? They try to label
me as a psychopath. They try
You said you were schizophrenic. You said you're schizophrenic
and I have a gun. Oh, I'm a dangerous man. I'm schizophrenic
and I have a gun. Let me remind you, I'm schizophrenic and I
have a gun. Really?
You not You not understand?
try to label me as a criminal to get people to stop listening
to me, but you got to understand, if enough people are trying
to get you to stop listening to someone, well, that means they
probably have something that these people don't want you to hear.
the most thought-terminating,
brain-dead cliche that's been proven wrong a billion times so
far.
Guys, if somebody's just screaming the hard R, they might get
banned from a platform. That does not mean that they have something
useful or or noteworthy to hear. That's
That's basically what's happening here. He's being banned for
using slurs on platforms that he knows don't accept slurs and
going, "Oh my god, I have knowledge. I have hidden knowledge.
They don't want you to know this." F-slur. They don't want you
to know this, says the F-slur.
I No, I think everybody knows that. Everybody knows that word.
Everybody's aware of your opinions. Asmongold
is actually more intelligent than you. He gives your opinions
better than you ever could.
On a platform where you say you get banned for for having those
opinions.
How do you explain that? Square the circle on this one for me.
Where How How does that continue to happen?
And that's why I pride myself in telling the truth at every time,
even when it gets me in I can rant, but realistically, we're
going to make it. We always do.
No. No, hold on, crab navy. It's not like, "Oh,
they're probably saying something that those people don't want
you to hear." Implies some sort of insight. It absolutely does.
But there is no insight. There's nothing
It's totally empty.
Life throws challenges at me every single day just like it does
for you guys, and I'm not going to sit here and be a victim.
I'm going to sit here. I'm going to get the [__]
up.
Dude, I'm not going to sit here and be a victim after his 8 and
1/2 minute victimhood story. There is nothing you like more than
being a victim, Techtard. You are the consummate victim. The
consummate cry bully victim on the internet. That is who you
are. >> to dust off my knees, dust off my shirt, and I'm
going to get back. Bro, why are you on your knees?
What? The [__]
That was just added for no reason. What the what? I'm going to
dust off my knees. What? Why are your knees dusty? Let's do it.
No excuses. I'm not going to live my life of being a victim.
We're going to do something about it. If you guys want to help
me do that thing, follow me on Rumble. I'll be live every day
from 9:00 a.m. uh CST to 1:00 p.m. CST, maybe even longer. Anime
reactions are coming back. Video game streams are coming back.
We have no censorship issues on Rumble. We're going to do some
crazy [__] on Rumble, and I hope you'll join me for
that. Um still going to post on YouTube every day. Just going
to really censor it just to make sure that my channel doesn't
get fully terminated because that's currently the direction of
where it's going. I got to be a good boy for a little bit, guys.
It's currently the direction. By the way, the thing that he is
in trouble for copyright strikes, I think. Right? That's what
he was saying. Copyright strikes stick around for a long time.
Copyright strikes are [__] up to deal with, okay?
That's that's the real issue. Community guideline strikes, they
drop off pretty quickly. Like you can go back to streaming or
or doing stuff again with a community guideline strike and not
be that concerned.
Right? It's the copyright strikes that sit there for like 3 months.
Or at least I I never had any problem with the community guideline
stuff. It's the copyright strikes that were really mad annoying
cuz you never know when another one comes down, and it just eviscerates
your channel.
Anime reactions aren't going to help.
Will he be able to control himself with the anime reacts is the
real question. What is he going to say about little girls this
time? >> I'm sorry. I'm going to try my best to make sure
the content stays as similar as it can, but unfortunately,
uh we got people watching us right now. So, hope you'll come
to Rumble. Hope you'll support my streams, and I'll see you all
there. Bye-bye, guys. Let's go.
All right. More reactions going on. We got a quick Miskif reaction.
What did Miskif have to say about this? Did Miskif say something
crazy?
What did he have to say? Rebuilding everything from the ground
up, because I actually believe that Rumble is a platform.
DUDE, OH, I THINK HE TALKS ABOUT Sophia here. Okay, I know I
know he talks about Sophia. I saw the I saw like her name in
the quote, okay? And I I had a thought, too. Dude, how do you
feel if you're Sophia, who just got engaged to this guy,
like he's having these schizophrenic meltdowns, despite being
confirmed not schizophrenic, apparently. Sophia is his his fiance,
this girl.
She just got engaged. He's rapidly You got engaged to like an
OTK Chad who had a ton of money coming in from streaming, and
like during his transition into politics, he starts getting banned
from
He is losing income sources like one by
He's apparently secured this Rumble contract. I don't know how
much that's for, how long that's for. Everybody who's done that
has lost significant amounts of audience. It has been a horrible
decision for them in the long run, right?
Chad, well, hey, he was in OTK. He was making a ton of money,
okay? How old is she? Like a decade old younger than him. But
don't worry about it, okay? Don't worry about it. Yeah, that
age gap is like a decade, but I don't worry about Hey, don't
worry about it. I think she's like 21, 22, 23, somewhere in there,
okay? Somewhere around about that. Now,
what is she thinking? This guy is like losing his mind. He's
slowly getting like more and more deranged. He's He's Now, apparently,
he's going to stop streaming on YouTube. He signed a Rumble deal
to stream. Like, the prospects from where you started the relationship
to now have done nothing but fall, fall, fall, fall. And I do
wonder if that starts to get to somebody after a while. Especially
when they're all unforced errors in the way that Tecktonik's
errors are, right?
They're all totally unforced errors. Honestly, Gregor Samsa,
I'm not saying there's something like morally wrong with that.
It's just like telling
there's something about somebody who is in that age range who's
going to consistently go for somebody a decade younger than them,
right? Consistently. And they're people who haven't had that
relationship with like the very emotionally immature person and
can be like fooled into something. You know what I'm saying?
They're looking for somebody without experience. That's all.
That's all.
And if you're consistently doing it, it's just a little bit weird.
>> believe that Rumble is a platform where I will actually
be safe on and not get banned for some Now, I now want to see
Miz's point. >> It sucks that I have to worry about the
sanctity and the longevity of my channels, but that's just what
happens
Wait, I just noticed Mizkif put a put a sweater on Ninja. Put
a Put a shirt on
I just noticed he did this. That's >> You're a guy who
tells it how it is. Like, imagine being Sophia. You're like cleaning
a dish and like that or like watering a plant and you see your
future husband just yelling at a camera about how he's banned
everywhere, no not allowed to do anything, abolished by all this
stuff. He's getting removed from his own job because he said
some guy is Like, dude, it's just like I wonder how she feels
as the tears fall from her eyes wondering that this is the man
that she's now going to marry. Please, someone, if you are in
the area of them, do a wellness check on Sophia. We pray that
she is okay every day. Sophia, we hope that you are all right.
Uh we believe that you were one day will hopefully get past all
this and move on from TeKtOnE. And uh we hope that you will one
day
be able to be free. We hope that you can one day be pray for
you. We love you. We care for you. We pray for you, Sophia.
I know [__] about this I don't give a [__]
about her, but Miz loves her apparently, okay? I don't I straight
up don't care about TeKtOnE's wife at all. It was just funny
to like think about the fact that she signed up for something
totally different, okay?
And it's way different now.
I hope she finds someone not scared of What? I think he's implied
that that's not the case anymore. But I don't know if that's
true.
I feel like he did that spitefully. That was before he went to
court. He was talking about how like, "Oh, I've totally overcome
my fear of that. I I've like I have no problems with anymore,
guys. No problems at all." But I think he just said that to irritate
Pink cuz I didn't realize that this was like a problem in the
relationship where he would not
her where where she wanted and he would not give her right? So
when he says, "Oh, well that problem's not a problem anymore."
cuz I think there was some some meme in this direction that basically
like he didn't want to Oh, yeah, cuz I think Frame said he'd
never had with her basically only had like a couple times in
their marriage. And so people were talking about he's like, "Oh,
that's not a problem anymore." He wouldn't even touch her, bro.
I mean, no, he would just not in a way that she wanted, okay?
Which by the way is is what the definition is. I When he did
that tweet that was like, "Oh, um have you ever heard of a assault
victim who is begging for more sex?" It's like, "Brother, do
you still not understand that consent means that she wants to
do the thing?" That's the problem that she would have consented
to that apparently.
Apparently, she seems to say so, so I have no reason to doubt,
okay? I And mentally, I do doubt. But you know, she said it,
so who am I to say? Okay, we Apparently, there's a Nux Taku reaction
here, okay?
We got a We got a Nuxanor reaction to the Teccentriq situation.
His bald head was promised to YouTube 3,000 years ago, and they
banned him. Can we get an oy vey in the comments for my boy?
Sorry. >> situation is diabolical, dude. His bald head
was promised to YouTube 3,000 years ago, and they banned him.
Can we get an oy vey in the comments for my boy
I can't Is this him like I I don't think he is, but in my head,
I'm like, are you trying to signal along with like the anti-semitisms?
Is that Is Yeah, anti-semitism, not isms, but ism. >> I
understand, he was removed from YouTube for like uh making
comments about Hasan [__] being gay for Asmongold.
Now, I'm going to be honest, he was graphic, I'll be fair, and
I'll also be an extra layer He got a community guideline strike.
That's not getting banned.
That's like a a maybe call it a temp ban from streaming. >> I'm
honest, I have gotten temp banned from streaming and I accept
that. I've gotten strikes for very similar things in the past.
They consider it derogatory
content. It happened to me when I called the Prime Minister of
England gay. I got a video removed and a strike on the channel,
so I fully relate. Apparently, this has been happening a lot.
A lot of people uh specifically woke people are trying to weaponize
YouTube's copyright and abuse systems to get people banned and
silenced. This happened to me also.
Woke people are abusing the copyright
Dude, I You can't abuse the copyright system. You can.
You can, okay?
But like basically, every every content creator that's on YouTube
is 100% on your side if you're having it abused against you.
All you got to do is post, dude. I would have been totally on
I I despise this WestGee guy. I would have been on his side entirely,
but the copyright strike thing. If he was getting copyright struck
and it was totally like fair use,
that [__] okay? Every content creator should be on
that same page. If you're actually having the system abused against
you, point it out. People who you It will shock you how many
people will be on your side.
Cuz it's everybody's livelihood that's at stake.
But when you don't point it out, I do kind of go, "Uh, is that
going exactly the way you say it is? Are you really Are you sure
that this is happening? Are you sure that this is the the thing
that's actually happening here? Abusing the copyright?" Yeah,
so Tech Tone said copyright from Hasan. He said copyright at
the beginning of the video. I believe he says, "Hasan gave me
a copyright strike. They've been abusing the copyright system."
But then he talked about a community guidelines strike, not from
Hasan, just from YouTube.
So, I would like to see the proof of the copyright strike from
Hasan or some Hasan editor. Another time recently, I'm excited
to talk about it. All right, let's see what's happening to the
bald guy. Hey, what's going on, guys? I haven't seen y'all in
a week. And we'll give you guys a TLDR. But at least he had his
Genshin Impact baddies to keep him company. videos about to be
about. I'm going to tell you guys why YouTube is currently underneath
the process of terminating terminating my channel, as well as
I am now going to be streaming exclusively live on Rumble.
All right, if this dude's not getting paid millions by Rumble,
this is a huge
Rumble, you better be Wait, THERE'S NO WAY. WAIT, WHAT? NO! NOX,
DON'T START ON TECH TONE. NO!
IT IS A MASSIVE L. BY THE WAY, little known fact, I guarantee
you that a bunch of these platforms are not giving him sponsorships
off of Rumble content. They're not going to sponsor you to stream
on Rumble. They're not going to sponsor you, right? And that's
where he was getting a ton of his money was from Genshin Impact
and Are you really going to go on Rumble and stream this? What
What platform wants to advertise Genshin Impact on Rumble. If
he sold Genshin Impact themselves on streaming Genshin Impact
on Rumble for a substantial amount of money, he's a
I can't see it.
So, I got to assume every income source is basically being done
away with just to go to Rumble. So, it must be a lot of money.
>> paying this bald ass, all right? You better You better
be paying. I was wondering, he literally texted me like uh a
couple days ago, "Hey, do you stream on Rumble or just on Kick?"
I'm like, "On Kick." And he's like, "Oh." Well, anyway, well,
there we are. Which the link is underneath in the Dude, Kick
gives you so much money, too. That's the crazy thing. If he's
streaming exclusively on Kick, he'd be making so much money.
He's He's forgoing so much money. >> I would appreciate
all you guys giving me a follow. >> Yeah, go follow him.
>> YouTube videos will still be on YouTube. However, I
am not streaming on any other platform besides Rumble from here
I don't stream on YouTube for this exact reason. Uh it's too
dangerous. It's just too dangerous to stream on YouTube, all
right? My main income is on YouTube. It's not on these alternative
platforms. And uh you know, you say something that the YouTube
overlords don't like, they will you I mean, they will dis they
won't like it. Yeah, I shouldn't I I have to refrain from using
commentary like that. But uh yeah, that's what that's the plan.
Yeah, I do Isn't there ads on Kick now? I don't think so. I've
not seen ads on Kick. Have you guys seen ads on Kick? >> Same
thing. here until the very far future. All right. >> So,
let me tell you where I've been and why you guys haven't seen
a post from me in now 7 days. >> That's a community strike.
One community strike, sir. Um So, I am a content creator where
>> going to do this whole thing. I do want to hear the
first part about the copyright strike, though. >> that
I pride the most in myself is being able to be as transparent
as possible. >> Well, thank god he doesn't like pride himself
for like his hair. been allowed unless a Dude, how are you so
unfunny?
How are you so insanely unfunny? >> ality comes into play
where I get to tell my chat everything that I think He like paused
to take a run up to that one. So too bad he doesn't talk about
like huh huh huh huh
his hair. >> everything that I want to say and the exact
way that I want to say it. In other words, he doesn't shut the
[__] up literally ever. That's what he's trying to
explain through very very verbose and beautiful terms. He he
has the inability to shut the [__] up. That's what
he's trying to say. However, what's going on right now is >> speak
so I could I could translate. there is a parade of content creators
who are currently abusing the copyright strike channel. Wow,
he's getting into the copyright stuff. He's right. Um Let me
tell you a story. The copyright strike channel. I made this because
you know I I don't like getting into like these little mini tiny
drama segment things as much. Uh but the reality is Nick Shirley
made a video exposing fraud in California.
His video was removed from YouTube because someone copyright
struck his video and it was all his content. Meaning it was a
false claim someone claiming that their content was getting stolen
and removed Nick Shirley's video. Not only Nick Shirley's video,
but they went after Asmongold's reaction to Nick Shirley. They
also claimed they owned the actual footage and they took down
Yes, the copyright strike stuff it the copyright system can be
abused, right? But it's when it's abused by the actual content
creators that it doesn't get resolved that's really
That's the real problem. Okay? Imagine having to speak this way
into your 30s, it's rough. Um I mean, I don't Dude, you say this,
but like Johnny Depp speaks like a character all the time into
his like 50s and he makes a [__] money. Realistically,
if all you got to do is make a funny voice to make money, I've
no judgment for that at all.
Yeah, I know. Reaction to Nick Shirley. And not just Asmongold's
reaction to Nick Shirley, this guy, too. I was covering the fraud
that Nick Fuentes uncovered in California and my video got removed
for this copyright strike as well. All right, and and it was
some Egyptian guy that was claiming to own all the content in
the video. The reality is, in my opinion,
So, did that get like fixed immediately
was that one of those woke Egyptians? Do you find Hey Nux, do
you find those Egyptians to be very woke?
How woke are Egyptians? >> Leftist circles. They want to
silence you by any means necessary. And now that you don't have
Facebook and Google submitting to the Biden overlords on the
COVID crackdown,
they're using more nefarious means to do it. They'll try try
to demonetize you. They'll try to hit you across the head with
whatever claim they could say or they'll just lie and claim that
you stole their content when you didn't. So, this just happened
to me like a week ago. uh feature on YouTube.
Number one, all right, Hasan [__] Bro, And I [__]
you not, this >> So, I get a lot of my Hasan videos demonetized,
basically. But, I figured that's just cuz I talk about like terrorism
and
I don't know, animal abuse, terrorism, like all the Hasan allegations
are not YouTube friendly. But, um Just real quick question, do
you get your videos claimed by by Hasan, Nux? I mean, the answer
is no, but dude, I I didn't even think about how absolutely patently
insane it is for him to claim
that Hasan would be copyright striking his videos. HOW DOES MORE
PEGASUS EXIST if Hasan copyright strikes videos he doesn't like?
There are entire channels of nearly a million subscribers that
are built entirely on Hasan. What the [__] are you
saying?
Um but, damn, I didn't think he was actually abusing the system.
Just happened today, Baby No Money. No, Baby No Money has copyright
struck West Jet. No, woke
Dude, as far as I know 050,
Hassan doesn't even copyright strike
the live stream that runs during his Twitch stream. He lets some
dude like restream him on YouTube.
I've not seen that go down. Now, maybe it would eventually. Maybe
I'm guessing I'm guessing if Hassan became aware of it, he asked
him to stop cuz I don't think Hassan wants his concurrence draining
way to YouTube and he's not even benefiting from it. But like
I don't think he'd even done that. So, wild. Rappity aye, baby
no backbone. He copyright struck Los Jet. Los Jet, I'm going
to message him right now. That's hilarious. Sorry for your loss,
but anyway, that's funny as well. And Hassan copyright struck
my channel as well as Ariana >> Hassan copyright struck
your channel,
I'm in shock, dude. I can't I'm almost as shocked as Kaya. Grande.
Yes, so we currently >> think that was personal.
I'm almost as shocked as Kaya, too. I think that's just a her
team is have a couple warnings on our channel as I was okay.
Dude, I just
I just want to say great. You know, if you found it funny, cool.
But what I would say is I do believe genuinely that he is shocked
because he's done a bunch of videos on Hassan, never had a problem.
I think Teccy done I'm going to say it outright, Teccy done's
obviously lying. Prove it. Prove it, prove it, prove it cuz you're
This just doesn't happen. You got to be lying. Now you get subbed
in. Got to feed the meter. And the reason why for this one will
blow blow your mind. >> All right, let's go. Out of everything
that I say on this channel and I guys, I get it. Sometimes I
say some crazy things. I don't really think I say anything too
diabolical, but all I said was due to and I'm going to have my
I'm going to have to censor a lot of things that I say going
forward. Hence why I'm very glad I'll be streaming on Rumble
very soon because what's going to happen is I'm going to stream
completely uncensored on Rumble because I've never heard of a
single person Thank you. >> for anything they've ever said
and then I'm going to have to sanitize it a bit on YouTube unfortunately
just to make sure my channel has a much higher chance of not
getting deleted while these copyright strike claims come off.
So what I said >> again that the you know, self-censoring
is nothing to do with copyright. YouTube has two systems in case
in case you're unaware. There's copyright and there's community
guidelines. Oh, yeah, Tech Tone is really wildly going back and
forth between the two. Obviously lying about the Hassan copyright
strike. I think I think Tech Tone wanted to make a move and he
basically decided that he needed to make a move based on some
something happening. He got a community guidelines strike that
would not have been been because of Hassan and he is trying to
farm the Hassan's bad algorithm to get more people directed towards
his Rumble channel. That's what he wants, okay? That's what he
really really really wants. As many people going as possible.
So he's going to say, "Well, the
my YouTube channel is going to be terminated." And then he's
going to say Hassan a whole bunch in the first little bit so
people get directed over to his
And then he could be like, "Oh, if you want to see somebody hate
on Hassan, come over and watch me on Rumble." And everybody's
going to say the [__] is Rumble?
So Good luck Tech Tone lines. All right, both of the If you get
three strikes in either of them, they remove your entire channel.
Now, the copyright system is really easy to abuse. Basically
anyone could claim that you're stealing their content and YouTube
will just trust them immediately. They they just believe whoever
makes the false allegation and they'll try to take your videos
down. Um and then you have to fight it and then if you prove
that you won, then essentially they they let your video go back
up. Now Okay, I don't need more of Knox. Uh maybe there's good
moments in the Knox video, I don't know.